this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
it's hump day energy and uh one of the
things about me is that uh every day is
hump day you know what I mean and by
that I mean I'm at the top of the hump
not at the what exactly is hump day it's
still okay it's like yeah Thursday would
be like it's the middle of the week I
guess it's the hump it's gonna get over
the hump get over the hump it has
nothing I hate those kinds of I hate
those kinds of conversations and
expressions because they're basically
make you weak well I'm almost over the
hump well I don't like characterizing my
life as a mountain well well you also
don't work at nine to five where you
know that Wednesday is a beast you got
two more days like if you're doing that
office grind yes well my mom was in that
it's like Wednesdays they're like yeah
Thursday Friday you know they're getting
over the hump I can understand that yeah
sometimes you'll see like I don't like
that I don't like negative and I don't
like overly positive there was a real
estate agent I was looking at property
one time and the guy had he was like in
shape kind of a bigger robust guy sure
uh in his 50s short military hair and I
look at him I go were you in the
military right he goes I was in the Air
Force yes I was and I said okay already
I'm already it's aggressive and uh and I
said well you laughed and I said I said
I said yeah what what uh I said
something else I said you look like you
stay in shape and he goes you know I'm
54 years young and I never say anything
that makes me feel like I can't get out
get through the day I like this guy and
he just went through his whole Tony
Robbins speech and all I said was you
look like you're in shape and I saluted
him and I bought the house he sucked
them off I sucked him off he sucked him
off did you not why did you turn okay
because I mean you're the one that
started asking about his physical
address
you could have said you sucked them why
did I have to do why do I have to suck
them off that's gross we gotta finish
the job I don't have to it's okay you
gotta finish the job you never finish
the week strong no hump day would be he
humps me no you gotta close the deal
that's not how you close the deal you
leave them want more
signed the dotted line and there's more
where that came from right more of
sucking up yeah if you if you if you're
talking about they're like oh this is
great I'll see you soon huh and you're
like whoa the only time out of the one
night stand yeah you want to come back
for more that's right we gotta finish
the job is the point I don't have to do
anything dude I don't know why you're
saying that and I think you have Homer
erotica and I know you're a gay because
of those shoes the Vans those are
amazing and you you finally got some
cool new balances and you've got my new
kicks bro but you're wearing with
business sucks I sure look awful and
that doesn't work no you can't do that
no did you finally get some cool stuff
what kind of socks should I wear no
socks no no just normal [__] socks
dude yeah white sure not business little
businessy yeah don't buy socks at Men's
Wearhouse or Amazon that's exactly where
I buy them but in fact I'll do one
better I buy them at Target not anymore
but I did before they went on target
when they went on nine billion dollars
or something they lost yeah well don't
have don't have pink shorts and tuckable
shorts for eight-year-olds you you
pieces of [__] I just don't know
companies would learn you just you
pedophilia yeah you would learn who are
you marketing to who's this for I have
no not the man some some crazy
Fringe wing of the world that are so
crazy yeah I just are hell-bent thoughts
just it never works for anybody do you
know what's bad I'm gonna change the
subject so we don't get uh docs on
YouTube because they won't let us talk
freely but um the ultimate Fighter's
back oh yeah did you watch it well I
finished the Conor McGregor document not
talking about that not talking about
that right talking about The Ultimate
Fighter finish the com that that's old
you've covered that well we haven't
really covered it or have you covered on
your others I've covered it multiple
times yeah it's all because out right
it's been out for a lot yeah but it was
I finished it yesterday but he's on The
Ultimate Fighter yeah and so ultimate
fighters
channel it's finally on you know it's
not on like you know the US ESPN plus
like it's on regular ESPN so they're
trying to get the views back now I
assume the views are gonna be high this
first episode yeah but I so I watched it
it debuted last night I watched it
I I don't and I love Chandler I love
Connor it's it's missing something I
don't know what it is but it's missing
the secret sauce and then is it missing
the secret sauce or is that format just
is too old it's too outdated interesting
because you watch it and I found myself
being like you know there's a conflict
seem forced or something well but the
Chandler and Conor are cool like they
have respect for each other and Connor
they're not fighting they're they're
gonna fight each other I'm saying but
they're not they're not color does this
thing but there's no animosity like
Chandler respects them so you don't have
the animasi the coaches it's really not
about the fighters this season is
prospects versus veterans which to me
kind of is not not what about the
Baltimore fighter should be about you
can have a veteran season yeah where
guys so the the veterans are guys that
not military veterans the veterans are
guys that fought in UFC didn't go well
and so they're bringing back a second
time you know prospects who are trying
to get the chance fighting UFC so you
have the pros the young prospects
fighting the veterans can you bring up
the cast which the the show's always
been you won't know anybody nobody does
so for Jason Knight but the show's
always been about young prospects get an
opportunity to showcase so they can get
to the UFC
so you have these young prospects who
want to get on into the UFC you have
guys who have already been there I don't
like that mix that rubs me wrong you
don't lie just because this should be
all prospects well you know I like a
second chance though that's kind of
romantic it's a different show yeah
because then the prospects are beating
the [__] out of the the the I'm sorry
the veterans are being [__] out of the
prospect will they though yeah you know
they will Brian please listen so you
have the the veteran and Roosevelt
Roberts fights this young guy Nate uh
gentleman it lasts 10 seconds he knocks
them out in 10 seconds oh no you don't
well so I will because listen I don't
have any inside info I'm not you know
spoiler I would assume the the veterans
absolutely annihilate them because these
veterans you know Robert said I don't
know everything he went four and four in
the UFC he's had eight fights so you put
them in the Apex Center that's not [__]
to a veteran they're like okay for these
prospects it's a big it's a live stream
they're all they're all tight and [__]
yeah it's just not fair and then also
you the way they did the drafting of the
veterans and the prospects it's like you
know you don't know any of the fighters
they go all right all the prospects are
with Chandler all the I'm sorry all the
prospects are with
um all the prospects are with Connor all
the veterans are with Chandler so 16
veterans or eight veterans six or eight
and eight prospects and they just do it
like that in this group picking so you
don't learn any the names of the guys I
just I don't know the house is cool
maybe the season goes on it gets better
yeah it's just it's missing something
yeah
so you think Connor's Connor he gets
there you know you know I love Connor
day one he gets it to the opening day
with making the picks he's in a suit
here's not done looks like they've been
partying all night in Vegas you're like
all right so he don't get [__] then
they do the weigh-ins he don't show up
to the weigh-ins he didn't no well he's
going he's I was thinking about well I
really they show him training with his
team he's just jacked really because I
in shape I I will say this like um what
I got from that Doc is that he's coming
off real losses and it's got to be such
a mind [__] for him you know it like
anybody like you know you want to talk
about everybody's saying you're done
this is it for you you've lost twice to
uh you know our boy uh Dustin
there's a lot there's a lot there
there's a lot there that he's kind of
dealing with I think and it's like if he
loses to Chandler now
oh boy there's a lot riding on that so
that's what I got from it is that this
is almost like everybody keeps saying
this is his last hurray what I really
respect about him is he loves fighting
he just wants absolutely kid right off
Sunset right now doesn't need to do
anything he doesn't want to do that he
just lets the warrior spirit and which
is why you love Connor right maybe let's
take a little break okay speaking of
breaks I will be in La Jolla The Comedy
Store this Friday Saturday Sunday two
shows Friday two shows Saturday one show
on Sunday the Lord's day me and Big Jay
shop will be cruising around San Diego
The Comedy Store this Friday Saturday
Sunday get you some tickets at
thickboy.com nice uh okay guys yeah my
neck of the woods dude comedy words
Denver I'll see you at the end of the
month you know um I like if you're gonna
drink if you're gonna have a party and
you want mixed coffee you know what
messes me up dude what sugar all the
sugar that's why it gives you those
crazy hangovers and then a friend of
ours into some June shine it's my go-to
right now dude it's an adult beverage
and margaritas oh vodka sodas rum [__]
no adding sugar so big man my wife was
talking about this she was oh I had
people over and oh
people love it you got the margarita
pack four different flavors you got
spicy Mango Tropical and lime you got
passion fruit and vodka soda classic
vodka mule
um it all comes in these variety packs
they got Mai Tai you can get the mix
pack but yeah you can get just the
tequila pack you can get the margarita
pack the passion fruit vodka is so much
sugar so you don't like candy you don't
get that brush you don't get that
hangover oh some of it some of those
sugary drinks with alcohol where you
feel hungover have over 20 grams of
sugar not June shine and it's
ingredients it's made with ingredients
you actually pronounce June shine can be
found over ten thousand stores across
this country it's available at all the
retailers you've already visited for
groceries and alcohol like Whole Foods
Target Ralphs Vons Albertsons Kroger
Wegmans Total Wine BevMo Safeway and so
much more and we got a special offer
foreign
you can buy one June shine Baggers and
get the second for only a penny Penny
that's a 12 to 20 in value I recommend
trying one of their best selling variety
packs a great way to try all of their
delicious flavors go to June shine.com
slash fighter text them a photo of your
receipt and they'll venmo you
immediately it's a good deal yeah it's
June shine
j-u-n-e-s-h-i-n-e.com slash fighter June
shine well I always have some macadamia
nuts running through that pop nuts like
Al Pacino dude well listen dude and
that's why you stay young and strong the
omega-7 fatty acids back profile in uh
macadamia nuts are probably the best
they're probably the healthiest
um nut you can buy here's the thing it's
just a healthy option it's a healthy
option for snacking I love their
chocolate covered that the the white
chocolate they got the regular dark
chocolate they got the raspberry vanilla
chocolate produce inflammation they're
key parts of longevity because they have
that Omega seven Sherman acids and
macadamas they're known as the most
expensive nut just for the rich not
anymore because our friends at House of
macadamia they work with 96 South
African Farmers to make it more
affordable for you guys all right it's
farmer own bro do you not like Farmers
Farmers farmers who work the the soil
I'm telling you the difference between
us in the snack bars they're so damn
good we always have the dip chocolate
ones here on set give them a free box we
give them to all the guests we love them
dude I'll give you a favor box give them
a free box and take 20 off their first
order okay deal all you gotta do is go
to House of macadamias House Of
macadamias.com
t-f-a-k You twins off your whole order
when you order the vanilla chocolate the
regular chocolate the snack bar 20 off
delicious that's House of academias.com
TFA K you 20% off and they toss in a
free bag of The nimbian Salted
macadamias namibians Namibia Namibia
namibian bay
salt from the Bay from the sea they're
nuts from Indiana no I'm sorry
that's House of macadamias.com House of
macadamias.com tfa-k 20 off your whole
order plus that free bag of sea salt and
macadamias you're welcome
right yeah I told you that doc bummed me
out because like ah man the ride's over
all right now you can if and he has a
really good chance of being Chandler but
it's just like he might have two three
left he did a interview with Megan olivi
and he was like I'm gonna fight three
times in a calendar year it's like cool
but as far as like the prime Connor like
that's over and that makes me sad
because I don't think we ever see it
again
that the documentary made me sad I think
it gave people a perspective of oh
Conor's not just this out of control
fighter that's doing all these
Shenanigans like you realize he's such a
tout once in a generational Talent yeah
realize how much he loves fighting how
much he puts into it the Heartbreak of
it all you get all this from that
documentary which I think it's good and
obviously people have their opinions on
Connor and some of the stuff he said
about khabib and stuff so whatever they
don't like him some of the outside the
Octagon antics you know slapping the old
guy and stuff that's I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about when it's
Conor in his prime yeah and what he did
it was such a special time and we're
never going to see it again I wonder I
wonder that that business is fighting
she hadn't broken his leg would have
been what did it same would it have gone
differently prey I did Adam on his back
let him back up
um you know you you got a slug fest with
Conor and now that he's you know in in a
kick faster you better pack a lunch
anybody
I don't know I mean
I don't know I don't know broke his leg
so it comes I think he's he's not in his
prime you'd say no yeah no how could you
say but I I will say that against
Poirier for the first round and this is
saying not much but he looks really good
but again it doesn't matter not in his
prime yeah like the ride's over now the
ride over meaning rides over as far as
you're not getting Eddie Alvarez version
of Conor you're not getting the Nate
Diaz rematch version of Conor rides over
meaning you're not getting Prime Connor
but I'll take a older Connor who has
more money than God that's pretty
[__] that's a good ass product feels
good how old is Connor
was it 34 I think
he's had a lot of fun he's been in the
game a lot 10 years yeah but before that
too right so he had remember he was
fighting in England for a long time cage
Warriors but yeah but
10 years in the UFC 34.
it's up there's a lot of wear and tear a
lot of training but the whole ultimate
fighter is predicated off Conor McGregor
because you know Chandler's not like
this he's not gonna say anything crazy
or do anything crazy he's just a good
coach he's a great coach you know so
it's really you're gravitating toward
their banking on Connor bringing the the
views I'm curious are ratings out for
how it did is it too soon highly doubt
it yeah I'll be curious how it did I
just I don't know if that
are the like when you had Michael chasa
and those guys on they had such
personalities that you got invested in
them ah GS is a bad example I you know
there's when he had Kimbo Slice that's a
bad example because she has to remember
like Chad said there was drama like she
has a cried like you see a fighter like
that and you're like damn this guy's so
emotional then he comes back and wins it
there was a lot of drama in it is what
I'm saying not not so much on his season
there was drama like Chael Sona and
vanderly they hate each other they
fought even outside the house then you
have you know in my season had Kimbo
Slice he had Roy Nelson some real and
Rampage and Rashad [__] hate each
other no this is 2015. oh okay that's
the first thing that popped up so 2015
it averaged uh 622 000. I would say this
debut does around
ultimate 513 holds stay at 1.3 million
you know I I bet this one does because
ESPN I don't know 400 000 debut it's
fair to say yeah
you know I don't know or the Conor
infectious massive
I got to it which was Ultimate fact 13
is that Conor and Uriah
what season was that and they didn't
even fight
Lesnar
uh dos Santos
interesting
yeah I'm so curious to see how the
ratings go for that because it is The
Ultimate Fighter hasn't been a good
product and I don't know how long
like the Pena Amanda Nunes one I didn't
watch it all the dicks no I couldn't
take it they also have they also have a
guy in the house who's already won The
Ultimate Fighter
what yeah Yuri won what yeah what are
you talking about Nick or something uh
he already won you're like okay I guess
that makes sense he's already been
through it
they came in it ain't working that's
really McGregor's training partner too
yeah McGregor's train person McGregor
had a few guys in the house that he
wanted on wow I mean he got to the other
team though yeah another thing you know
I mean Chandler said that when we had
him on the show we saw my Ultimate
Fighter they shot all this in four weeks
when usually it's six weeks so the guys
are fighting boom boom boom boom yeah
so are you do you feel comfortable just
putting if you had to put money on
Chandler or Connor that's right whose
team wins on those providers and they
fight you know they haven't announced
the fight so let's see but you know
let's see at 55 right
yeah I think 70. we don't know yet they
haven't said the weight either what
you're told yeah Chandler's like we
fight he Chandler's like I fight you 85
and and Connor's like cool he's like
you'll do what you're told because I've
run this game I own this game I always
have it's always going to be like that
he said you'll do what you're told
that's the other thing is like when it
comes to [__] talk too like it's not
don't get involved no it's like it's
like Trump and Biden on the debate stand
like it's not it's not again it's not a
knock on channel it's just not what he
does that's all Connor does it's like
that's what Trump does he throws a lot
of mud hopefully something sticks kind
of throws a lot of mud so it's gonna be
tough to get somebody on there to
compete with them it's you know so yeah
challenge if this debate gets announced
was Trump not available because he could
fight uh that'd be great that'd be great
it's kind of like DeSantis and Trump
excuse me excuse me before you kick me
dude you're small his wife looks like a
dog you know what I have way more money
than you do
his wife's a dog like you're talking
about global voice everyone's a dog your
whole your whole team of dogs
I hope it goes well because it's a good
outlet for you know Fighters but it just
doesn't make sense I I don't know
there's something about it it's missing
I don't know what it is yeah you know I
root for The Ultimate Fighter that's
where I got my freaking name off yeah
but I don't like that's Prospect
veterans they should end two separate
seasons of that it's about finding young
talent and building them up giving them
a fan base these other these these
veterans have had their shot man so why
um why when I watched that Conor
McGregor uh documentary why what it
sounded like Conor couldn't get a fight
they weren't giving him a fight that
doesn't make sense I feel like he wins
in the documentary he's like I can't get
a fight and I kept I kept trying to get
a fight and finally had to start
tweeting at Dustin himself but what was
that about who knows I mean there's a
lot that goes into it because the Conor
fights different than the rest right a
lot goes into at the timing the
marketing the right opponent because he
was trying to fight just anybody and if
he's like no we can't just talk to
anybody why because because he's the
cash cow so much goes into it you know
it's a lot so yeah Tom Cruise movie
right because he wanted to fight three
times a year to keep his rhythm and they
were like no I'm very surprised by that
I thought he could choose his fight
anytime anywhere you know no it's a so
it's a circus must be the right things
have to go come in this play WoW because
Tom Cruise movie and so many people like
you know yeah yeah that's right it
[__] him though he hated it hmm let's
be active yeah it's the only way to
fight well I agree can't blame them for
that because after the Donald Cerrone
fight he wanted to go right into another
fight
but then there's certain guys are tied
up they can't just toss you the number
12 guy because nobody cares and they
don't waste that because they make so
much money the risk to win lose or lose
again that we don't have another product
also Nate's fighting this guy we need
Nate to win so it's like all this stuff
has to line up the UFC is not just going
to waste you know bust their nut off
just man you lose again we don't have a
what are we gonna do you're our biggest
Cash Cow and then also who I don't know
where that the time on the ESPN rights
the deal like you are Cash Cow you're
the one that's the reason we're going to
get most of this money so if you lose
that fight we're gonna lose money on
this like there's so many factors it's
not just like yeah fight whoever you
want no so much again become a victim to
your own success the the the the you
could encapsulate why I love MMA so much
in that first the second Dustin Poirier
fight you know where Dustin started
kicking his legs and they plan for
everything and it was the one thing that
Mike Brown said kick his [__] calf
and that's why Mike Brown was a champion
in his own right but that that that was
like they probably were like [__] ah we
forgot about that check the kick but no
he's not we haven't worked on that yeah
it's just like it's like anything else
you work on chokes you work on all that
and somebody starts arm leg locking you
like what I didn't uh you know
oh God the pain he was in you want to be
a fighter huh you want to be a fighter
he literally ah like the pain walking in
like I was in that dock too I think it
gave people kind of uh an Awakening how
Connor's not your typical fighter
because the way he talked to Dana after
that khabib fight when Dana comes in the
back of America khabib jumped out of the
stands goes for Dylan danis and there's
all this Mayhem and he's back there his
kid and wife's there and he's you know
he can't believe he's lost he's tearing
up and dance like man how about that
Louis khabib did you see what happened
he goes I don't give a [__] what are you
talking about yeah I lost the fight
because I know but did you get people he
goes hey it's not about that I don't
give a [__] about all that bollocks I
don't give a [__] about this what are
you talking about he's like I lost the
goddamn fight you're like whoa I've
never seen somebody ever stand up to
Dana like that oh they're they're pairs
they're they're Partners he's not just
an employee they're partners
get the [__] out of here I don't have
time for that he did a really good job
against khabib stuffed a lot of
takedowns people forget yeah people
forget yeah he did better than anybody
has ever done again this could be
wrestling wise it was interesting here
as coach uh John talked about he's like
it was such a dark Camp he's like such a
dark time everything was negative dark
all he did is do his own thing go and
then he was like this bar like this Spar
sparse bar bringing wrestlers give him
trying to get him take him down he's
like it was a dark time you think we've
never been around a camp like that damn
he did well yeah
man I don't know that's you you I lost
my mind in this game
I lost my mind I lost my mind on this
game yeah I wish you sounded like him
that's so bad like I know what you're
trying to do I lost I lost I lost my
mind I lost my mind I lost my mind on
this year just off man it ruined it I
lost my mind on this did you sound like
you're talking normal game
boy he's a special dude I'm Irish I'm
Irish no there's a guy in Ian Gary who
could carry on that tradition the Irish
takeover is seeing gear kid who you
don't know that's fine yeah he's a
Savage 135
no look
let me bring up Ian Gary
educate Brian Ian Gary is he a monster
in 170. he just beat Rodriguez starched
him the boxer
Daniel Rodriguez
Daniel my Rodriguez got good hands yeah
he's a tough dude oh yeah
killer
and get another cage Warrior Champion
too look how many look at that he's won
a lot is that all UFC though no oh man
right
good beach
I hate when I bring up prospects hold up
you know Ian Gary oh almost sharks in
UFC oh Ian wait oh Ian Wright Ian Gary
yes
oh Ian Machado Gary yeah this kid oh I
know that kid
I know that kid right okay fights at 135
no 170. yeah yeah
well no he did the tribute kind of back
in the day
uh he has the tools to do it he's not
you know he's super confident too
kicking box but again it's tough because
when Connor did it it was we haven't
seen it before now it's been done so
it's yeah you can carry on the Dublin
tradition become a major star and stuff
you know people rally around oh yeah
yeah oh yeah you can tough I can talk
man super confident too
has a lot of Conor mannerisms but again
it's been done yeah so that's why I say
it makes me sick because we're never
going to see it again because now
anytime you see something like that's a
version of Connor
here's the original that'll be someone
else who'll come in with their own stamp
but yeah
maybe he was so colorful
still is Connor did make it so different
from jail though like jail is the
original uh yeah it was original but
Chao did in a very WWE way where it's
remember Trail was like you know after
the last day on civilizing I'm still
undefeated there's a big difference one
is real well so did I'm saying Connor
won two belts and he took on when he
beat Jose Aldo Jose Aldo had hadn't lost
in nine years Jose Aldo was as good as
you can't believe it and he knocked him
out and he said he was going to do it
and then he got went to 55 and he did
this he knocked he knocked our boy the
difference is like his jails is like a
trolling WWE and that he's a big WWE Fan
and uses that model and Trail was also a
Grappler who wasn't getting any respect
because he was kind of boring so he
decided to do this to get Fame it's very
similar to Colby Covington with Connors
it was like like when you hear him talk
and we've heard people talk similar like
I'm Gonna Knock this guy out when Connor
said it and was like I'm telling you man
you're oh damn he's actually this is
pretty authentic like he's real Savage
we're not here to take part we're here
to take over like yeah that's
legitimately what he's trying to do take
out and he took him when we did the
podcast and I said what did you say to
Jose Aldo when you jumped over the when
he knocked out Chad Mendes I think yeah
and and jumped over the thing and he
said I spoke my I said my country and my
mother tongue I said era I screamed it I
was like [__] Savage yeah just he was so
[__] colorful man and then he looked
at me and he goes you're the one and I
said thank you because I love to always
have like wait what yeah always have
love you always have you know what boy
love you I love you always have yeah I
said Thank you remember that yeah I
remember that yeah any time you want to
train in my camp
you come by I was like thank you Conrad
I love you always have yeah
it got awkward right it got really
awkward and I was like that back kick
you showed him his back well don't worry
about it yep but he wasn't doing it on
the ways yeah yeah it's very interesting
me and Steven Seagal do a lot of secret
teaching
underground stuff too I get it yeah
remember I taught you back kick long
time ago and you were like in Earnest
like okay so let me see and I was like
yeah you go you never used it
no and that you know sums up you're like
you downloading like I'm just gonna
delete this out of my memory I was with
Nate marker in the prime of his career
we were doing shooting Warrior
and uh and I told him about fighting a
guy
I was with Sam Sheridan and Nate we were
walking and I told him about how I hit a
guy how I I like did it I thought I just
love when you share those I said I said
the way you swam and he caught him with
the top of my Knuckles and and the chin
and uh how he got knocked out and Sam
just started laughing he just started
laughing at my story because
you know it's Nate marquardt's yeah it's
just a waste of time don't talk about
anything around Nate marker when it
comes to fighting Brian
I would say in general though right like
old fight stories yeah four though right
I was in my 20s I know who they for you
know right I think I was talking maybe
guys that came in you remember man let
me tell you about this one time I got in
this fight in Brooklyn's like don't care
you have video yeah you don't yeah don't
care yeah nor do we believe half of it
right right how much of that story do
you think is true how much are you
exaggerating right right so we've seen
how those fights now I don't exaggerate
no no especially when it comes to stop
fighting yeah
never why are you looking at me like
that George whoa I just saw this real
quick so since you told me you had never
seen Nate lose around
in training now no no no
he was as good as you you could be I
mean in his prime pinker's Champion
Strikeforce Champion came to the I mean
father Ash and Silva Chael sonen Okami
uh I mean
yeah you know handsome Nate
so this he did make some headlines in
MMA media because he was because I guess
you know Rogan does talk about the Bible
the scripture has changed after it's
Rewritten from different places
yeah so Nate's saying like he wants to
you know debate Joe Rogan but he's also
here's the thing he's also starting a
podcast episode one so in order to get
attention he challenges Joe Rogan you
know it's like
yeah
and also Rogan has done a bunch of
different people on right and it's
that's their perspective I don't know if
Rogan believes that so it's like you
know debate it's like you know the guy
the kid you know wanted to debate uh
Rogan on uh
it's like
you get attention when you do that stuff
but it's not the attention you really
want for Nate I guess getting some
attention for that podcast but it's just
not the angle you want to go
Nora's joking to entertain any of that I
don't think it works out
I was talking to Joe recently and I go
um uh do you worry about that he goes I
don't worry about anything
I was like that's you have [__] you
money so you're that worry about what
like this stuff we were talking about
something and he goes I don't worry
about anything like why would you yeah I
was like that's fair that's fair
that's that's fair that's when you know
you've kind of arrived when you don't
worry about anything nor would you pay
attention to it I mean also he doesn't
deal with the same issues we have he saw
in hindsight he saw the Direction
YouTube was going with freedom of speech
so he's like oh I'm out I'm gonna go
where I can say whatever I want Joe
we're like we're gonna stay here okay so
um I always used to Marvel at again I
was talking about this reason I used to
always Marvel at his ability to find the
problem in the room so Joe could look we
could be in a room and Joe could go like
this I swear to God it was uncanny he'd
gotta like that guy or why are you
talking to that girl get away from that
person he would go like this he didn't
like them and I'd be like who you've
been around that no yeah here you go um
get away from me or he'd be like I'm not
talking about that guy and you'd be like
what the [__] dude he's a nice guy
that's mean right but but guess what
he's right always right right I know and
so I listened to this um I don't know
who she is but she was saying when you
are a child and you come from a chaotic
background around adults that are
unpredictable so so an abusive childhood
whatever
children get really [__] good at
reading a room and finding the person
that is not the danger yeah exactly and
and I didn't grow up that way and when
you grow up that way that that's he's
always been very cautious and avoided
trouble avoided crazy
people yes women and men
it's a superpower it's a superpower it's
astonishing too because he can literally
waste time he can literally hear I
remember we were talking we were getting
our makeup done we were doing this silly
movie and a guy started talking and Joe
goes like this Joe goes what he goes
like this he goes wait say that again
and the guy said it again he goes man
just like this he goes wow what a
[__] artist holy [__] you're such a
[__] you guys like wait what like
this and I was like this I was like I
think we're gonna fight I'm sure we're
going to fight because you and I will
entertain it yeah oh really and the guy
was like and he goes you're the biggest
[__] wow we need a little bit of
more he was doing this he would that was
it though he was like well this was
before he was famous I mean he was just
like this guy's a [__] [__]
artist yeah and I knew that I if we were
gonna hang it out that that was done
with that guy yeah
he was right he was right always is you
know we need a little more of that in
our tank
we entertain all sorts of I can use that
I if I can go back in time I would say
hey young Brian listen to me right now
don't waste time don't dig every say no
to everybody and keep everybody but your
family and three people uh in your life
small circle yeah keep your [__]
Circle small
okay we haven't talked because we had
Jay Moore on Monday I went camping oh
went to RV
I had to how great no I lasted that day
I was texting with you because the the
problem is the RV they didn't tell me
this again it's not like um Shaquille
O'Neal or Charles Barkley like you know
it's not like I'm like hey are you sure
the beds I'm gonna fit in it I can't my
feet were hanging off the bed I got no
sleep I woke up the next day and my
girl's like what do you want to do I'm
like go home we're going home she's like
it's been one night I'm like yeah we're
going home 100 we're going home she goes
you look exhausted of course I'm
exhausted where would I sleep Joe
she's like you couldn't sleep I'm like
how can I where would I sleep you can
try to sleep in the tent
there's no tax it's hard to pitch no
there's no tent the kids don't want to
sleep with a tent so I go why would we
drive two hours in the middle of nowhere
sleep in a [__] car and sleep in a
shitty hotel yeah on Wheels that's what
I say and I go check please check please
kids kids had the time of their lives
they were able to sleep in the camper in
the RV open the thing they absolutely
loved it talking about slept together my
girl's small so she slept great my
in-laws slept on the sides they were
great and then they go well you want to
switch
everybody in the same room no that was
fun that part I loved we're all in the
same room I love that when the family's
all on top of each other I love that
that's what I did like about the RV but
the BET after returning I go
um listen I don't rent it for three days
I'm bringing it back you're here earlier
I know I know um no you're tired I'm
tired listen you didn't tell me this
when I rented this RV it's made for
small people yeah and I'm not a people
not giant but also I'm not small you
could have told me I would have slept on
the bed right yeah they should have said
you're enormous and we got to do
something but it's not like I'm [__]
you know Joe kids from the Denver Nugget
six four I'm normal it's not like
outrageous right
Brian zero sleep and I go I'm gonna
return early so the two days I paid for
I'm gonna need my money back shoes
absolutely not I go what do you mean she
goes well you rent you can take it now
if you want but it's yours till Saturday
yeah I know but I can't sleep she goes
um that sounds like a you probably go it
is 100 but you never told me that's not
gonna fit she goes again you rented it
till Saturday
less food so I don't grow as much you
[__] [__] otherwise give me my
money back I had no argument she goes
but what do you want me to do all right
I I don't know give me my money back she
goes but you read you already paid for
the two days we can't rent it out
because it's in your name yeah so we're
gonna lose money
I went okay just give my license back
and I walked out and ate [__] yeah I
slept where did you guys go how far away
two hours I don't know where'd you go in
the woods
no no no no do a campground you know you
were in camera you know what it was
we're at a park okay I'll be honest
there's sidewalks yeah and when we
parked I looked at my father-in-law I go
listen I grew up camping right we're in
the mountains you know like clear the
rocks out and put the tent I said Steve
we're camping at a park right now I have
a problem with that and I go you know I
can't set up a tank that's why I go
because there's sprinklers
because they're sprinklers yeah where I
come from that's not camping
well I was invited now I my wife is 33
and my she has 33 year old friends 30
year old friends 28 year olds you like
Al Pacino so what happens by the way and
so what happens is bring up Al Pacino's
girlfriend and look a little smoke
shirts 29 years old he's 83. he's Al
Pacino I know um but but so um get this
she's she's 29. what is she doing though
right she's pregnant she comes from a
wealthy Kuwaiti family so she doesn't
need the money she comes from a wealthy
family she needs to fame I don't know
what it is she dates uh
she dates nothing but old billionaires
it's so interesting it's what she's into
she clearly has a fetish for that but
Al's not a billionaire Alice got a lot
of money
and Alice out that's her there I don't
know if that's her that's a problem oh
that's her best friend okay I was gonna
say that's probably that's her she's
it's so interesting do you think when
she comes home
and she goes hey Mom and Dad I want you
to meet Al Pacino and the prince go yeah
cool what are you doing hanging out with
the Godfather is that the guy from
foreign
so look I admire her
look at her
I admire it I'm impressed and for
what is happening though he's it it's it
and he got her pregnant and they're
about to have a child and he's 83. so
listen hey when that kid's 17 he's a
hundred he's such an amazing Alex does
he die for the kid turns 17 for 3 000
please no
right yeah I don't know man that poor
kid think about the poor kid he's 83.
now financially the kid's gonna be fine
but the pork
is this not [__] up I have no problem
with the ages whatever at 29 you're
allowed to make whatever choices you
want whatever you want to cut your
wiener off date the grandpa do your
thing you're a grown woman you're
basically 30. you can do whatever you
want but to bring a child in they can't
you're gonna be a hundred when that
kid's you're gonna be 99 years old when
he gets his driver's license so he can
go up without a father he lives Chili's
100 it'd be amazing
you want to bet right now he doesn't
he's a small man small people live
longer I'm just saying even a hundred is
tough these days well especially the
miles on him yeah it's a tough one you
can't lift your kid yeah
so every time I feel like an old Dad I'm
like okay he's being helped here real
quick when like when my kids in
literally get seven he's gonna be 90.
so the kids can be like [__] dude yeah
hey Dad let's play catch I can't no I
can't why because if I do I'll [__] my
pants yeah if I get up I'm gonna piss my
pants son yeah okay I guess that's how
dads go it's not it's almost like you
don't want the kid to get attached to
you
because you're going to be I'll answer
that you're leaving he's not going to be
attached why because if I'm the side I'm
her I'm go Hey listen he's just
basically a sperm donor yeah don't get
attached
but a kid you know kid gets attached
something I mean not to a 90 year old
he's not changing diapers at 90 Al
Pacino yeah and he's not doing any of
that um
she might want to go back to Kuwait and
just oh no should I have the baby he'll
be a young Al Pacino look alike and then
she'll move on with some yeah for her
good move he's got two 20 year olds but
you guys have problems with Leo
because he's eating box in the 21 yeah
he's not getting him pregnant
and with Al Pacino we have a pass pick a
side it's I don't have a problem with
anything just for the record
so his kids suffer from uh
but his kids suffered from rheumatoid
arthritis they both have very bad
arthritis so they have they suffer from
very bad immunity
clicking on the one of the with him with
the glasses that there's one
Brennan yeah that one Brennan Brandon
ain't that a [__] just hold on ain't
that a [__] I'm not gonna say anything
she's got she's had very bad health
problems oh really yeah with just
arthritis or yeah it's rheumatoid
arthritis it's a terrible disease really
awful
ain't that a [__] though your Al Pacino
and that's your squad
is that his son that's his son too [__]
dude man sometimes dude you can't have
it all yeah so those oh this is my thing
Brian you can't have it all well those
kids they can't have it all you can be
Scarface and somehow sometimes the ball
doesn't roll your way God wait you know
what Al you've had a good run right
because I sure has his children I'm
gonna give you the two ugliest kids
saying that listen there's a bad
pictures they had rheumatoid arthritis
you know what you're right what's the
angle so you're right it's the angle
yeah it might be the angle and also it's
interesting that Beverly D'Angelo who
was one of the hottest she was from the
National Lampoon which warlock you
talking about bring up young Beverly
D'Angelo this is that the one on the
right no they're young that's where
that's where the kids get the looks
well this is Young Beverly God ain't
that a [__] yeah but you know and you
you just wake up and you go [__] dude
that's that's their mom right there
that's there she was so hot when she was
younger oh dude yeah she was great yeah
she was in uh the uh vacation yeah yeah
hilarious yeah that's right yeah she was
great that's his wife that's right
that's who he has two children no no no
no no those are not the kids of Al
Pacino and that is there and I've worked
with her uh twice and she's uh three
times and those aren't the kids Beverly
no that's not Brian those are kids or
somebody else I promise that's you Brian
who's that on the right over there
that's just his girlfriend I I know
that's not his girlfriend Baba I know
where have I speak here
Al Pacino is Wikipedia will show up the
the spouses and kids I'm get that's not
them that's from a different marriage
Papa it's from a different marriage look
at me he has two children with Beverly
D'Angelo those are the kids it's all
good
no it's not I'm telling you those those
are different kids
I'm telling you no just go to Wikipedia
yeah it's gonna show spouse kids because
he's had a few wives I'm no I'm saying I
know he married her B but those aren't
the kids Papa
you need to listen to me now there's a
partners
okay they have they have three kids so
Beverly D'Angelo uh two kids so the Lucy
the Pollock the the Pollock
the Pollock right Pollock who's the
Pollock Lucia Pollock that's where he
had the kids yeah because you know how
old those kids would be if you had them
in 1997. Jordan has the info right now
yeah if you just Google Olivia Pacino
that young lady her parent her mother is
Beverly D'Angelo 22 years old don't
argue with me ain't that a [__]
don't say anything I'm done it's very
nice she looks pretty there she's cute
bring her up bring her right there yeah
that's all it is is a bad picture
yeah let's bring her over there no leave
that picture right there let's see
yeah that's her right there
yeah she grew up yes she is she doesn't
have the braces anymore yeah she's a
cutie see depends on the picture it
depends on the angle that's all it is
they really screwed over those other
pictures there are plenty of guys that
are all about that let me tell you she's
cute oh yeah
keto G it's his birthday make a wish dog
that's it that's a that's a that's a no
she's grown up the pictures that they
have that we were looking at to be fair
were not very good get braces and all
that and there she is that's a sexy
curvy woman right hey all right calm
down take it down I'm just telling you
what it is I know what you're doing
right now take it down that's a that's a
beautiful curvy woman there are a lot of
guys I would be all about that
that's crazy their mom's that Beverly
D'Angelo uh-huh
she's 71. damn
it comes for all of us Bubba times
undefeated but she is
gorgeous oh yeah
no pushovers and they're still married
oh no they're not married because he's
married to that oh that was a I think
that was a rather contentious
relationship but they had two children
two firecrackers God bless them yeah
when you get two actors like that
together you can only have one headshot
in the household that could be a real
situation yes her her career was booming
but it's booming unless you're married
to Al Pacino and business is still a
Boomin yeah
yeah
so you believe his dick still works the
swimmers still work so I knew Al's I did
a movie with Al's other girlfriend the
lucila she's from La Argentina nope
she's from Argentina I did I had my
scenes with her and she said yeah there
she is she's great one yeah she's great
and let's put a look yeah and I did a
movie with her and she said he is a
[__] alpha male all the way and let
me tell you a couple things about Al
Pacino if you if you don't mind I
watched him in a play when he was I
don't know
67 70. and his arms were as jacked as it
gets wow that's her daughter wow
um his arms were as jacked as it gets
yeah we've seen more jacked arms though
I hate to hate on them they were just
yeah I want you to bring up Al Pacino's
arms Jesus he's an alpha male and I met
him and he feels like a piece of wood
he's made of a p when I when he was
dating her I met him at at Sloane's
house but I met him back then and he was
made of wood made of [__] wood no
when I think of Al Pacino I think jacked
I swear to God Bubba his arms were like
this big I don't know why 20 inches arms
huh they were huge yeah huge biggest
I've ever seen I'm not kidding yeah I
don't know why that's not showing there
because it's not true it's not true
right I don't like I don't want your
opinion I love Al Pacino but nobody's
gonna say that guy is Jack maybe not
there dude name any other actor he's not
the guy that we're going for Jack just
go here's an older one that's how that's
that's pretty he's the same arms as
Robert De Niro those are 14-inch arms
those are 14 inches he had large arms
yeah you tell me the World Wide Web
doesn't have a picture of Al Pacino's
jacked on his arms right there
13 inches and hairy
yeah catty is a great actor yeah there
you go that you know what that movie is
for 10 points anybody
played a gay uh a gay uh cop posing as a
gay man looking for a serial kill God he
is just very much damn dude I look out
of my gum I think Jack he has a life
force in him that is like you know see
there you go that's the narrative is
that it because when you say Jack life
force we all check out life force huh if
you want to talk about Arnold Sylvester
Stallone Jack we say those are jacked
men Al Pacino is the furthest thing from
Jack well when I saw him in a play he
had his sleeveless shirt and I was I was
taken aback by his impossible arms yeah
it's still not jacked though and it's
power
yeah
he's one of those guys but I got a piece
on him he's five every bit of five do
you believe his swimmer's still [__]
work at his age to get a young girl
pregnant I'm saying
that's insane or shirtless yeah I did
that earlier all right five six wow
five six and jump not a tall guy not a
tall guy
yeah phenomenal Talent though oh I mean
God
I mean come on
I mean it's surprising that you can
still get women pregnant at that age
I've never heard of that
happens
I guess
I mean I mean I guess you don't hear
it's not a lot
because it's rare that the swimmers
still worked then it is
but I don't know some guys it's very
it's not that uncommon I bet you it is
chin type up what's the chances of
getting a girl pregnant after the age of
80.
to me like less than one person yeah
yeah get off you'll probably live till
he's 120.
how do I get my brain to work faster and
better at your age better memory at your
age there's nothing I can do for the
rest of you yeah you can try Alpha Brain
the number one eutropic on the plant
they sold over a million bottles and
they got all sorts off of brain free
please go back to all the Alpha Brain
well they got Black Label they got black
uh Black Label is what I like they got
regular Alpha Brain if you haven't tried
start with the regular Alpha Brain and
get your money back if you don't love it
Focus it'll be fun necessary you don't
have to send back the product you get
your money back so start with the
regular Alpha Brain they've sold over a
million bottles they have Alpha Brain
instant put an eight ounces of cold
water tastes delicious then the Alpha
Brain Black Label that's for the big
boys that's for the pros in this Alpha
Brain Focus shot Alpha Brain pre-workout
wish I could finish that and I'm
interrupting I'm just saying the
supplement game is so full of crap
there's so many people that that are
peddling crap and on it is the one
company you can trust we've worked with
them for 10 years yes 10 years and they
have the best nootropic on the planet go
to on and
the instant the regular the Black Label
the focus shot the Pre-Workout plus all
the supplements protein powders creatine
the workout gear we got it all streaming
Fitness go to audit.com save 10 off all
Alpha Brain products on it.com
f-a-t-k 10 off
what's the oldest you know how they oh
you know how they say that that person
lived to 120 and stuff there are people
that that that there are a lot of people
are like um
like we don't know what their birth
certificates are like a lot they don't
know if that's actually true Cuban
boxers yeah most of this is just based
on women
yeah
oh there it is one percent
there it is one percent there you go
he's a one percenter
makes sense though
you're 83.
29 year old wants you
oh yeah I'm in aren't you going I'm not
hating on them aren't you going what no
no I'm not questioning anything no no no
no no yeah we want to go on the yard
really yeah if I'm Al Pacino you would
you want to sail the Caribbean yeah I'm
getting a a 30 year old to suck this old
dick yeah are you kidding me yeah my man
yeah my man right
Heaven's raining down I still got it I I
still got it
but you know you don't but still got it
yeah but you don't the fact that he can
still [__] too you know all of it's
fascinating I'd love to see how that
went out
I'd watch him do it
no maximum age but of course there's
going to be you know sometimes there's
going to be issues oh go that can an 85
year old man produce sperm
there's nothing tiger when a man's sperm
production stops women aren't born with
all the eggs they ever have men on the
other aren't able to produce sperm cells
for their entire lives
it says it might be hard to get an
erection not if you're Al [__]
[__] Pacino you know which Bluetooth
that man goes through I bet that's
incredible
it's probably taking testosterone there
must be something going on with like you
have a daughter she's 29. came home with
an 80 year old boy something you'd be
like weird I messed up as a father
that's right right you'd be like well
she might have I failed she might have a
genuine fetish
so I have a friend
I have a friend
yeah I have a friend who's a wife
maybe ex-wife now the mummy she was in
genuinely into
uh old man porn like if the man was old
with gray hair I mean that's different
than five oh so she's like like Grandpa
like she's into the grandpa that's what
she was into for real there's some inner
childhood yes yeah she was into that
so you know yeah so listen there's
there's I dated a girl
I dated a [__] girl who was into Old
Men
and I mean when I say old men 75 years
old was hot
but like well-dressed like tall yes yes
wealthy old yes yeah bro Al Pacino's
five six eighty years old cappuccino
that's my thing take his Superstar out
of it and we're like what the [__] this
is a headline we're like that's
disgusting it is because because it's Al
Pacino we're like hell yeah yeah because
Leonardo DiCaprio like hell yeah anybody
else like huh yeah what's going on Leo
will be doing the same thing
when you see them what see the thing is
you have to remember too when you go
anywhere without Pacino before you get
there there's a stir
even you know it's like oh in the
kitchen like you know I'll put you know
sitting down at 8pm yes the stewardess
are like [__] here we go here we go
yes who's gonna land Arnold
Schwarzenegger same thing I'm me dude
I'm cleaning my ass I watched his new TV
show fubar
you're bored huh yeah yeah yeah why
would you right why would you that's
okay
not so good
that's the thing because if your
daughter came home like what she how old
is she 14 now 15. so she's 15. boyfriend
too yeah let's take him out of the
equation uh she came home with you know
when she's 30. yeah with a 85 year old
not named Al Pacino you're gonna be like
what do you what the [__] you doing yeah
because you a you're not gonna have
quality of life you're gonna be taking
care of him you're gonna be a caretaker
that's what you're gonna be and you want
to have a kid well you're raising that
kid by himself because let's just odds
are he's already past the average
lifespan what his average life is 85 86.
so he's on the verge of that so you
might have him for another two three
years you'll be a caretaker that babies
don't grow up without a father you would
be irate dude let's be honest if it was
an Al Pacino
it was just a regular dude cut his
throat women's uh
women 79 men 73. he's way past that
dude 20 73 is when people die dude that
scares me because my parents
my dad just turned 83. that's and he's a
big fella big fella
and uh that's scary for me that means 10
years of podcasting for us
right dude right no
that would be 16 years from now so be
cool oh yeah 17 years
it's nuts dude
good on L swimmer's gonna swim as far as
gonna swim I bet he was shocked when
she's like babe I'm pregnant he's like
get the [__] out of here
yeah from the one time in Costa Rica so
I had um I had two scientists on my
podcast
and uh they've all listened to him so I
can sleep tonight it was good actually
it was really no I'm just kidding but
but
um they were talking I'm doing debates
now on my podcast and I think it was
after the podcast uh they were saying
how men can they think people will live
till they're 150 right there's that's
all the thing now like kids are being
born now that will live to 115. but
we're past that place
there's there's so many hurdles to that
um because of what the structure of the
body right the structure of the body and
how how gravity and sells and diets yeah
it's like this idea that we that people
are going to be living so much longer
with new drugs is not true it's not what
happened is 75 years old might be a
point where you are you can keep more
muscle mass and like you're gonna die by
85. well you're gonna well but isn't
cancer a big leading cause of people
when they die older it's not just cancer
it's like entropy and size right like
there's a lot of factors your size your
diet but there's an overall physical
like um so it's there's something called
entropy there's something called as
things mixed together it becomes more of
a like kind of mushy Mass you know I
don't know look up the look up what
entropy means but there's so many things
that just kind of break down
over time that you just can't like
they're just sitting with the
advancement of of Technology like can't
we prevent some of those breakdowns
everybody a thermodynamic quality
representing the unavailability of
systems thermal energy for conversion if
you're taking care of yourself you're
eating right it's a degree of disorder
or Randomness in the system okay so the
degree of disorder and Randomness grows
as as time goes on
lack of order
to slow that down no are you sure that's
a that's a that's a
um a reality in physics that's a reality
and where there's nothing we can do to
stop with energy and matter energy and
matter you cannot avoid the Trap of
entropy so as you get older it's not so
much that time does it it's called
entropy even if time body breaking down
physics will say time is is not what you
think it is it's a relationship between
two mathematical equations blah blah
blah the point is that there is
something called entropy there's
something called disordered things
disintegrate as time goes on bottom line
I know I know
[__] we were talking about science
Brandon no I'm here sorry but I'm here I
turned the channel to science let me
turn it back to take jokes let me turn
it back I'm here you're right so there's
nothing we can do well it's a lot of
this [__] is [__] dude yeah a lot of
stuff is like nah I bet we there's
something we can do to slow it down also
I didn't look in there and think those
guys been a club Health you know what
I'm saying right
agreed
I agree all right chin what do you got
uh first
happy birthday 24 years old
[Applause]
happy birthday
to you
that cheesecake is cardboard flavored
that cheesecake is cardboard flavors
because it's keto
swallow it even the cupcakes and cake is
keto yeah is it made of unsweetened
cornmeal that's not nice someone made
worked hard for that I think it's like
almond flour or some [__] that's what
you have to eat though dude that's why
he's last saw that weight you piece of
[__] you're a good man you're still too
you're still too young to date Al Pacino
my man yeah maybe his daughter maybe I
need some House of macadamias to sweeten
it up nice and chocolate dipped that's
what Brian gave you for your birthday
and by guy I mean an open Package well I
was just eating them yeah he was
happy birthday buddy happy birthday it's
been one year since you guys hired me on
the show on my birthday last year damn
look at you now dude now we're almost on
episode 900. you're doing you're killing
all the clips you guys see yeah do we
have a guest
I don't think so but how great was
George J Moore [__] day we got he
made me laugh
that's stories man that Ralphie May
story The Donut yeah that's God right
there that's what God looks like and the
story about rizza's kid oh that sounds
beautiful
yes good
Arnold Schwarzenegger is it good Arnold
Schwarzenegger once I mean steroid abuse
are dangerous excuse me sir people are
dying
yeah so he said he was on testosterone
and d-ball so full of [__] this is the
problem it's not authentic because he's
like when I was doing here he goes uh
when 75 year old bodybuilder in the 70s
he said he was legally did a regiment of
testosterone debault yeah that's it sir
although Baba and hey hey hey no no hold
on I will say this about their use back
then they didn't have that bloated stuff
right
now they do like insulin they do all
kinds of [__] that's HGH which makes
your organs grow that's why you hit the
but they're doing also like they they
insulin and so not just H but they do
insulin they do all kinds of weird [__]
right I think the steroids have gotten
more prevalent so watch this watch this
I'll do a little experiment for you
bring up Frank Zane no no you don't need
to do this and then and then bring up um
you know no no no they've gotten out of
control you know the you can bring up
Frank Zane and uh Ronnie Coleman but
Frank Zane's not even a good example you
could there's so many other body
so yeah when I look back at Arnold I
thought he was way crazier looking than
this but that doesn't look too good you
and I right like he's probably natural
right absolutely not go to when he no
absolutely not go when he won the
Olympia
that was the best body but not it's
become freakish but that's that's what
humans do we're always like we need more
and more and more so we put all these
demands on the bodybuilders like when
you want Olympia I mean do it come on
Jack
Ed
that's probably the best that's the best
come on man
it's great to me that's the best body of
all time maybe man maybe because it's
not it's not so far down the lane of
monster like freak yeah now bring up
Ronnie Coleman for me like look at those
tits that's that's a big boy
that's definitely not natural oh no no
it's natural but when he would go off
cycle on the off season it was such a
difference now Ronnie Coleman was an
absolute and that's when he got freaking
he was also a freak to begin with and
then with all that stuff nobody's born
like that though nobody freak look at
those two Jay Cutler another one they
just got so it got even crazier didn't
it as as it went on so then I went Phil
Heath and Kai Greene and stuff but that
that was really the Pinnacle of you know
he's 300 something pounds yeah it's nuts
your legs the body like look at his
traps Jesus
you got it it just got so weird My Lord
Arnold could have said like steroids
today and all the stuff they're doing
she did mention that so he's saying like
people are listening to charlatans like
people on YouTube maybe like just going
with whatever they say but he went to a
doctor or like he went full of [__]
it was him as a [__] Frank whatever
hey look at him there go back go back so
that's probably when he was off his
cycle right because he looks like to me
that looks like a really good natural
bodybuilder that is
he looks like he was probably uh he's
young there yeah
but yeah he had like connections to UCLA
Medical oh I'm sure facilities Arnold
was different all the way around always
I mean he's a special dude
um but there's definitely some bro signs
with this thing because steroids are so
new back then like in the NFL locker
rooms even back in the day in UFC it's
like it's all bro signs there was no
special doctors going all right take
this and let's check your blood level
he's full of [__] that he Bro Science
did it too yeah him and his buddy Frank
and all those guys and then Hulk so I I
uh now he wants to sit on his thing like
it is dangerous we had doctors they
[__] did it so you're popping d-ball
like Skittles at Gold's Gym Venice [__]
well so so the guy who uh who did
Pumping Iron I knew him I think his name
is Charles Gaines and in high school I
knew him and he he said there was this
black guy who was in featured in it it
was a bodybuilding he said he was eating
20 pounds of red meat a day oh yeah yeah
20 pounds
[__] crazy Plum and iron is great
this guy Charles Gaines a real stud a
real stud
you went to high school with him his
daughter
and uh
he was just a big athletic muscular guy
and uh you know really really successful
you can see what a study is just like
there he is there he is
yeah you know six four and you know yeah
look at Arnold there man
yeah he does look God damn humongous
Jesus
okay these look way different than this
that's him at Gold's Gym that's Gold's
Gym Venice yep that's from Palm and iron
you know what he did lifted weights made
millions of dollars in that sex with all
the women all the women
he said I'm coming all the time always
coming
I come when I was I'm in the gym and I
get the pump it's better than coming
[Music]
Franco Columbu Dr Franco Colombo
his best friend
Italian strong man
could could do dips with two guys
hanging off his waist two grown men are
hanging out yeah he did some gay [__]
back then like when they're doing like
deadlifts each other on their back yep
that prison workout I'm like yeah it
looks fun though man because they would
do that and then hang on Venice Beach
[__] all the chicks he's smoking weed
come on man this is like I'm Numero Uno
oh bro come on bro probably the best it
was also an outlaw like a weird
subculture sport that nobody knew about
it was like this weird it still is yeah
it is still is it's maybe more so now
right like like no no so but now there's
so many Jack guys yeah so now the the
availability of steroids is every corner
it's easy to get so now it's not so you
know and then trt's normalized you know
for the most part back then God damn
them boys were doing it right just
lifting all day twice a day in between
your [__] [__] saying your wiener
sucked he was a Arnold was a handsome
[__] what bring up
look at how handsome that son of a [__]
was well his son who he had with the
nanny is identical to him identical if
you're his other kid you're like [__]
dude yeah
and that but no but no look at how gay
that's the sun oh that's one of a son no
no go to his no that kid I know it's a
disaster
that's a disaster you know when your
dad's Arnold schwarzen it's the disaster
go to the the Mexican one bro
I identical to his dad now and he's in
movies he's Jack dude oh
no Maria no no no those are the bad guys
I'll say bad kids
look at him yeah I know it's hilarious
look at you got the genetics yeah he did
and he's getting into it too
he's lifting and [__] and he looks just
like him yeah the other kids don't look
like him no no he looks identical well
you know
when your dad's Arnold Schwarzenegger
he has the exact face and [__] yep
isn't it crazy
yep so similar
it's cool right here
oops
you know there you go that's all you
know well the kid's not juicing he's
just lifting weights he'll get there
we'll take him down that dark Road the
juicy Road he'll get on the juicy Road
can you get on juicy Road oh he's
getting on juicy Road homeboy shredded
right there he has the same face like
the mouth is the dad but the you know
kind of the similar I love it though I
love that he loves his son look at that
secret sound [__] it you're my boy
that secret went South for him huh
yeah but that's okay his book didn't
sell when I when that came out his book
died you know that oh yeah everything
kind of did it I was like well guys you
know everybody everybody was like that's
a little much dude you know come on
your maid
you know what I mean like I've made gets
pregnant and she's a woman I had a kid
in my house and he but he was like what
do you want me to do I'm in my [__]
room she's full of laundry it's like hey
don't [__] the maid is what we expect
and if you're gonna have sex with the
maid how about not having a kid with the
maid like that's and then running for
governor and be like I'll get away with
it and he did he got away with it yeah
and they were like he had a kid with his
maid and he was like oh look at this now
here comes here he comes with his
slinging dirt we know how he is and I
was like yeah you're slinging dirt at
Governor look at him though dude just
identical yeah really another kid's like
a beautiful mistake he had he had a
beautiful mistake he has a wonderful
child
you know you never regret a child it all
works out yeah and he is that he is that
[__] love solves all this ethnic work
you know what I'm saying huh like he you
know his mom poor upbringing so he has
that yes immigrant mentality you're a
nasty name but he has that immigrant
mentality yeah and he of Arnold's jeans
dude we're going sizzling because
remember Arnold had an immigrant
mentality he came from [__] Austria
came over here took the World by storm
biggest movie star Governor insane dude
Mr Olympia now the sun has the same work
ethic bro and Mom Mom you know it's
probably Ballin she's been taken care of
it's all good it's a good hope you know
what it is it's the Great American story
it really is rags to riches and I and I
appreciate the [__] out of it
yeah yeah it's not a sad it's one of
those things you're like I shouldn't
have done that but I got a beautiful boy
out of it so [__] it hell yeah
love conquers all
yep
I'll say good Brennan [__] off
[Music]
God bless that whole clan Leonardo he's
like yeah
look at that with a priest right there
Arnold Arnold just you wanted when and
how and you know his wife at the time
was like we're gonna hire her because I
don't trust you there's no way dude you
gotta have some self-respect there's no
way and he was like yeah that's smart
and then he was like hold up two weeks
in he's like you [__] up I never tell
you this my wife
my first one just nobody around yeah my
first wife hires a nanny she's
interviewing nannies and I remember I
met her in walks yeah
and Swedish a mix I mean she's sweet
about five nine she had this she was
dressed in Couture and I can't have it I
literally went I go absolutely not
you're not hiring her I'm not having her
around the house all the time I'm gonna
be dressing and paying attention to my
hair I'm gonna be self-conscious I never
that's not happening I can't have it
it's a disaster I can't have it I don't
need that kind of energy my nanny looks
like George Soros well can you not say
that on the podcast because she might
hear me shouldn't speak English okay but
still like I don't trust myself I'll see
you hire yeah
yeah there are people who you know hire
uh like a really hot assistant and no no
no it's like what are you doing dude
what are you trying to do because it's
gonna it'll that's all I'm Gibbler yeah
yeah Lions can play I don't trust myself
lines get blocked I don't trust myself
give me the ugliest one possible it was
very nice
accidents it's all good God bless
everybody yep
ready for another one yeah all right
so this was making headlines as well uh
so BJ Penn apparently responded to this
right here this guy so some hater bows
CT kicking hard lately and he goes what
a CT again did Ali have that what about
Jim Brown did he have that CT is fake as
the coronavirus okay well that he does
have his he does he has a brain surgeon
so huh you know everybody has these
opinions but they don't have a lot of
experience with this stuff they might
not have looked at the data but who has
be you can't look at data of the CT
until they pass away sure let me ask you
this what I don't have a lot of opinions
about it I Do I Do Right someone who
probably is going to suffer from CT if
I'm not already here's the thing
how many people in America play football
how many how many just let's go small
sample size NFL how many people play in
the NFL not a lot but a lot a lot like
you say let's say let's say a thousand
more than that yeah more than that but
let's say a thousand how many you know
sub from CT
I've talked to Old School football and
I'm asking that but how many do we know
for a fact they're from CT you know some
famous ones right Junior Seau think of
how long the NFL you know how many
people play high school football what
you're what you're saying is there are a
lot of people I'm going on football for
10 or more years and have zero problems
into their 60s that's right Michael
Strahan
17 years in the NFL before that you're
talking about 17 years in the NFL
probably played for 13 with college Pop
Warner 30 years of contact football
scores
the majority doesn't Brian but if you
watch the movie concussion you these
outliers the exceptions there's
exceptions I'm not saying CT is not real
but what I'd like to see is I'd like to
see a construction worker who's doing
this all the time and he passed away
does he have CT what about what about
the guy that rides motorcycle
snowmobiles
we look at football players but we don't
look at the worst conditions Aaron
Hernandez had horrible CT okay do you
want to say a horrible CT okay but the
majority of them are okay
but Dan Marino all the analysts in the
NFL
Troy Aikman who had many concussions
Steve Young uh Phil Sims Boomer Esiason
yeah all these guys so the numbers were
Bradshaw the numbers suffer from a lot
of depression but that might have been
because you went through a period yeah
but but just look at that sheer numbers
of all these guys that are actually
doing well and making it making a living
speaking that don't suffer from CT but
there's a few examples I can give you of
guys that have CT the odds are that
you're you're gonna be fine the juice is
worth the squeeze
so I think we're we're BJ I think he's
somewhat right somewhat right being like
not to say it's fake like Corona that
doesn't line up because CT is a real
thing we know for a fact to say that
everybody has it it's crazy there's
certain guys that have it yeah but the
majority of guys do not they're probably
a lot of factors number one a lot of
people might have some brain damage but
it doesn't affect them number two you
might you you have to also look at how
people were living in addition to
getting all that trauma were they doing
a lot of drinking drugs how are they
eating what kind of genetic
predisposition but I'd be curious like
you know you did Taekwondo growing up
being Rogan to taekwondo and growing up
did that give you CT so if you were
passed away I got knocked out sure sure
a lot of people are knocked out from
playing [__] kickballs so if if you
die and we study your brain they're CT
do you die from CT yeah like like does
CT show up on the brain even in the
minor times because we don't look for it
we don't we only look for it if like I
play in the NFL for how long this will
get the brain there are definitely there
is there are definitely people that
suffer in the NFL from CTE there's no
doubt that concussion was touching on a
very serious subject
but you know you're right I mean I think
the majority of people so Bo camper
remember Beau camper he played forever
and he he's 65 he's got all these
businesses I said uh you know we were
doing this radio show after the radio
show talk to me about CT he goes
honestly he goes all my friends that
played all my friends who are my age now
I don't know anybody who has that has
the issue now maybe they're not telling
you or maybe you don't know maybe your
depression is a symptom of it maybe you
forget things I don't know you know I
think it depends on how much punishment
you took
and what what you were built like and
but also you and I were talking about I
don't want to say the word because we
get banned on YouTube when you look at
people that got the shot yeah if you
look at the stats the odds are most
people are okay yes now there is a
certain amount of the population that
are not okay yes so do you want to say
that that shot's bad for everybody when
you look at football or fighting the
majority the mass amount to be able to
play college football high school
football pro football are okay there's a
few group in this group that are not
okay so do you want to say it's bad for
everybody right
right
yeah
I mean I agree it's like with with
musicians that go oh you got to have
depression and suffer bipolar and be
super negative or Comics have to be
super depressed and all this stuff what
the example do you have Kurt Cobain
Nirvana okay uh the the leads here from
Linkin Park okay the majority but how
many bands are there right I don't think
everybody suffers from Stephen King
creative people that have substance
abuse problems it doesn't happen the
creative you're a substance abuser it's
like yeah it's like all Comics all you
have to be you know dark and depressed
and come from horrible tragedy
my the majority of ones I don't know
are there some that have it yeah man
yeah there's some are and they're famous
for it so then people go oh that's how
you have to be who's the black guy who's
the black actor uh he's in Ocean's
Eleven
um
star characters and Don Cheadle was like
yeah but I I came from like uh like the
kind of family you saw on the Cosby's
they went to D I had a great family and
they all loved me and you know but those
famous outliers people are like oh man
all musicians are like Elvis no they're
not no
now there's some very famous ones that
happen to struggle with that it doesn't
mean the you can just blanket hear about
it when they're famous of course yeah
the 27 Club they die early well those
people did the majority of them they
said Amy Winehouse Winehouse so this guy
who knew her and followed a career and
stuff and he said they found Amy kind of
she was at a gas station and this is
before she killed herself and uh with
drugs but they found her
um about a year before and she was at a
gas station and she was kind of walking
in a circle she was doing something and
oh she must be on drugs and the guy said
she wasn't on drugs Amy Winehouse was
exhibiting uh behaviors that were she
was she was she was losing her mind we
don't know why but she was getting crazy
felonious monk so the felonious monk was
um so she so just real quick with Amy
Winehouse yes she did a lot of she was
an addict yeah but she might have been
doing that to self-regulate so she was
all to try to keep herself together she
was doing certain drugs and people will
do that if they already have something
going on her story is sad too because
then she was trying not to tour because
she knows when she went on tour she
would use all the time and she was sober
but her dad wanted the money he was like
no I lined up a tour for you her
management was like no no no she cannot
right now she's not in a place and her
dad's like no we're touring goes on tour
goes on stage hammered drunk dies
shortly after that sad sad story sad
story 20 whatever so talented so
talented but she just she had issues she
had mental her without the drug she
already had mental health issues
so
I'm a huge dick comment I do too let's
go pee
but no but painkillers that's why I know
for a fact if I had heroin dude
painkillers was like oh [__] yeah that's
fun really you feel a little I loved it
I got I got like hooked on it like oh
yeah you got some addiction things no I
had it thankfully I got over it but I
did have that addiction
mm-hmm
yeah I'm good at stopping his tracks
before it comes a big problem like this
is going down a bad Road and I can go
cold turkey like that's still between me
and Jay Moore Whoever has an addiction
I'm like oh this isn't good I get kids
I'll stop and I stop stop don't even
think about scary yeah I'm like oh this
is gonna go down the road I can take it
and throw in the trash I never think
about so that's after you have kids
though
painkillers I was taking a ticket and
then uh my friend Joe Clemson I was like
dude you're using these all the time but
see that's people intervening like no he
was just like using the time I'm like oh
you're right I haven't had one Adderall
same thing alcohol you haven't you don't
drink a lot I can stop whenever I can
stop the self-control to go no I'm good
I stop anytime I've partied I felt like
my brother or my dad and then that turns
me off because my brother died from it
and I've seen my dad fail miserably over
and over again yeah anytime I've tried
anything I've been like all right yeah I
just know the road it goes down I'm like
I'm good I don't want that nothing good
comes from doing a shitload of a
substance well you've never done it how
do you know you don't like it that's my
thing back what how do you know
wieners huh you don't know that's so
weird about Brendan if you try because
you know I've done cocaine if you try
cocaine I'm super worried nah it's
actually just like I'm super weird it's
just fantastic yeah yeah it is not the
same right no it's not no come on to me
it is I don't like either one I don't I
don't know you don't like anything
though you're a bad santa I don't do any
drugs and not even mushrooms I was like
micro dosing and now I'm like remember
you were like this Shaman all the time
like you don't want to talk about I'm
like no yeah when you have a good trip
though you think that you're on the
Mountaintop I had a I had a couple I had
some friends again my wife's friends are
all young and they hit me with this they
go we need to do a weekend a four day
weekend we're gonna go camp and do all
the drugs and I was like I'm 56. you got
like a quick question you guys can do
you guys videotape that for me let me
know how it goes and let me watch it no
yeah not gonna do it
this is my joke you know you never hear
a guy my age say this Summer's gonna be
sick Al Pacino says that he says that
yeah he says that he says that that's it
and you need to be more like Al Pacino I
do need to be more you're not far off
right you're not my wife's 30. 33 56 23
are different sorry Al Pacino light huh
Al Pacino diet Al Pacino I move well
I'll tell you that much I didn't know
she was 33. yeah
beautiful I'm so attracted to her I said
it out loud
never get tired of them never well no
she's young bro yeah you're 56. I just
like her as a person well yeah she fits
you're she's young you're old
it means everything right I don't know
about that you want to play this game
right no but I like being around her
this is Al Pacino
I'm around for young man yeah
keeps you young yeah there's a reason
why I want guys like young chicks geez
this is great that crazy talk
I never heard of that before that's not
that's not a through line throughout all
history yeah you should be in prison but
whatever what what do you got chin
no I've already been doing current
events
no he only did two we did like a few uh
so this one I thought was interesting so
off the coast of Portugal there's been
like since there's not that many but
since 2020 there's been three different
orca attacks on boats is there a video
of this yeah what but I don't know how
much I can show you see this one here
hold on
hit a sailing yacht they sunk it and
researchers don't really know why this
has happened because they don't want
them in their [__] water no so
there's like the females was was injured
yeah so there's two theories they think
either they're juveniles they're just
trying to have just playing around but
they don't realize how much damage
damage they can do and also there's a
mother that might have been injured by a
boat and she trained her you know to
[__] the boats up yeah so so so good for
themselves everyone's fine though
everyone dude yeah think about that
be terrifying once you hit that water
though oh my God
no they stop at the boat yeah and you
better get you know uh we're being
attacked by killer whales prank call no
no seriously no I saw black fish I'd
believe it so they didn't show they
actually didn't show the whales uh well
I mean this guy recorded the boat
actually getting almost attacked but
let's see you see right there they're
just swimming along with them
what look at look look how close it gets
gets to the motor
those are just silly gooses
killer whales doing killer [__] man yeah
so you see that guy he's like an 18 year
old he just graduated off a dare jumped
off a cruise ship
they never found him oh
you do you jump off he's all say less
jump what see ya what do you mean game
over he just he just I dare you to jump
off the cruise ship in the middle of the
Pacific Ocean he goes hell yeah no Gunk
and then went where'd Jim go and and oh
Jim's dead
hold on and he just jumped off do they
have a video of it young dumb and full
of [__] so he jumps off and then he just
they geared him yeah yeah but but
because the ocean goes we'll take it
from here yeah
he's a baseball star of course
let me see damn it dude come on kid
don't do that damn it he just
disappeared at night
yeah his friends dared him
dude you can't do it at night
my problem is uh what kind of friends
are gonna do you jump off a boat in the
middle at night they lose in the
Atlantic Ocean yeah they lose you kid
they lose you all the time and also
there are sharks
how would you jump in that water that
little oh [__] all right
hmm
hold on
yeah they didn't find him surprisingly
that's sad yeah you're more bummed out
about the friends like what are you guys
doing
what do you think was gonna happen
what'd you think he was just jumping
like I'm here throwing them you're such
an idiot when you're young yeah I was
never that I wasn't my friend's playing
ping pong on a cruise ship that one guy
loses he picked up the whole ping pong
table threw it overboard okay that's
crazy but not this you wouldn't be like
hey let me see you jump off the side up
they are too [__] you huge line gets up
close and personal with campers I wish
this happened on my camping trip what's
happening my friend no it didn't my
actually my aunt that never happened I
did no she told you oh Jesus they're
camping in Africa yes
there's rules of life you don't jump off
cruise ships you don't touch another
man's weiner with your mouth and you
don't if unless you want well you don't
know until you try it but then also you
don't camp in Africa also you don't go
swimming in Florida
these are all rules for Australia or
anywhere I said it out loud
yeah so it's just a male line just
checking things out
oh my gosh well you had food laying
around but why would you even camp in
this area that's just like insane look
at that
just like Giants dude that would be
terrifying and the person filming is
outside oh my God they're all outside
the terrible idea
they're all quiet angry alligator hisses
at River Rafters hmm
what happened it hissed at us
I don't like how those white people just
like check to get your phone out Greg
yeah like lock yourself look at that
dude terrifying that's a juvenile that's
a young lion guys I don't think so know
what that mean
yeah um
how many more you guys want holy [__]
that's an aggressive iguana
's usually aren't like that man that
thing's boring
I'll grab that also just flush it right
hey
okay so I know that's a
iguana that also got in the toilet can't
kill you so who gives a [__]
yeah everyone is so mad
so Georgie this is uh magamed Enclave
the light heavyweight and it was his uh
camper
he went camping in Russia
look at this bear attacking his boys
oh damn all that guy has that stick
oh my God this is where it gets crazy oh
like that appears [__] it looks like the
berry [__] was like God damn it that
bear is coming after him also you guys
had a net ass stick you guys had a log
he was like what are you gonna do with
that [__] bear don't don't try to
capture the Barrel in your dumb net and
the beer is coming dude yeah
we're gonna do that stick
you just dropped it yeah that's what
happens your dumb stick isn't doing [__]
dude I'd love to be first [__] sake
someone's about to get eaten ass first
yeah
oh here's a quick one uh this is oh yeah
it's cracked me up what oh them seeing
each other at the airport like twice I
guess yeah Twitter freaked out about
this I don't give a [__] that's because
they're they're from such far different
in Brazil and you know what uh New
Zealand and then they meet each other
like twice already and was Izzy flying
out of uh New Zealand and Alex is I
don't know which airport this is
Australia because I'm sure Alex is big
in Australia now especially fighting
Izzy so everyone knows who he is three
times so I'm he's probably pretty big
out there
and then this is Alex filming Izzy it's
all good and there yeah they're they're
super cool to each other professionals
what are they gonna do murder each other
no
two Pros
that's funny I love Izzy yes he's so we
all do he's the best
all right we good yeah
what's that six two dating is impossible
oh some big chick complaining she's
super hot too though
so she's six two she's saying she can't
find anyone to date even though she has
like you know her friend is taken
hold up go up it says only two percent
of the population let me see what she's
he's tall video please sir yeah
she's she looks like she's got it going
on she's hot
she's very hot uh and your kids would be
fit D1 athletes
she's six two she's six two damn she's
built too she's not like a weird sixth
dealer well she hasn't like a nice ass
too all right take it easy let me see
more pictures please
are you kidding me look
oh Brendan is so in
look at her six two what a freak yeah I
wouldn't have a problem with six too no
wait why is she saving seven foot though
I think she's trolling so after six foot
guys say they are tall yeah wow she's
been trolling since I I trust me I
looked it through a lot of trouble so
that's six foot but you and she's how
tall she says she's six two but she's
trolling heels she's 60. so that's not a
good so she's looking for a seven footer
she's basically a six two girl that says
she can't find girls or sorry I can't
find it pictures please
her standards six two is not like crazy
he's a hockey player a basketball player
ass right there pocket players are all
six years
she's cool Rampage is not afraid of that
I guarantine do me a favor type in the
average height of NHL players average
I mean I I you want to bet a lot of them
are uh
six foot four so you wanna say you want
to I guarantee the average NHL is not
even close to six three uh I'd say it's
six two bring it up Jen
oh well six three six one
where hold on no go back go back chin
we're back just go back
on average positions around six two six
one to six three roughly 200 pounds go
to how tall is that average male hockey
player but that's that's six one yeah
that's on average just just over six one
so we're talking six two no says six one
there buddy but a lot of them a lot very
common to see them six three six four
five
nowadays and and I'm not huge no huh
they're not like I'm gonna say like six
one six two who cares yeah it's not a
big deal she cares she cares a tall lady
yes but I went for a tall lady I would
say look for the NHL player most people
would say look for the NBA player right
well there are a lot of I mean tennis
players never base everybody's at least
16. but would you guys date like someone
that's six one not me but I'm not Ryan
can't would you are you like a petite
woman are you like a smaller curvy hot
hot so if she's six foot she's hot I
don't care
no no no no I don't care really no she's
and she's attractive for you it'd be
fine yeah I have no problem with it
huh
now she's at seven foot yeah I'm out
yeah so if it's a disaster six four
would be tough but they're like super
hot it's all good baby no no that was
nice just get off there right now guys
hello I'm trying to [__] the girl okay
but let me see more of her yeah she's
hot dude she's super yeah I mean she has
trouble dating she's still I don't know
what's happening
she probably has trouble just fine like
a good match
I've been reading this more and it's
like I think she's obviously lying about
the seven feet no one's got seven feet
oh and so that guy's not seven nine no
so I think she starts trolling after a
while but she's a tall girl
six two she from Brazil I don't know
well don't do that though yeah yeah I
don't do any of these videos I think
that's more of the problem
yeah she's cool man yeah that's her yeah
no problem
shout out to the guy that said I love
your feet
yes all right your kids would be
monsters yeah she's gorgeous that's good
for her kids will be stats mom is an
absolute giant she's learned some of
them aren't models tall in general like
real models
are six foot seven
because like the most women models are
six eight six but the models are the the
day and age of models are gone and now
Instagram models to go for everything so
you can be whatever but like the actual
models like Vogue and [__]
they don't exist it's so interesting
everything kind of changes with uh I
don't Gisele does who's that so
who Dash should we even do this one so
she's a a girl that is very popular on
Snapchat and there's like an AI thing
where she's going to become your
girlfriend right but you pay like 100
the dollar a minute a dollar thank you
that's expensive
but she's so like to me like she's super
like but she's your girlfriend
electronically yeah she's not but you
just talked to her just text and yes
she's a real person that she's you know
she signed off on this but it's over oh
but the ai's using her voice and
everything her voice and just send
pictures and stuff
it sends pictures it just it's mostly
just Communications oh so so it's like
that movie her yeah exactly
you know [__] lonely you gotta be
always she is so pretty she's so hot
though right yeah yeah she's cool I
think the taller girl's hotter yeah me
too
although no I don't dude I do dude you
know how you know how lonely you got to
be to pay an AI machine
I know dude and there's some guys
sucks so this one I thought was
interesting too
so this is a girl that was working at
you know as an accountant in Wall Street
right
so she started doing uh escort service
she's an Asian girl she doesn't show her
face exactly but you can see what she
looks like she charges
I think two three thousand dollars for
two hours good thing she blurred her
eyes out I know it's like it was so
stupid like she said she was a
psychopath
but in like a in a good way she doesn't
care about what people think this and
that whatever oh I mean like she's just
doing her thing so she's saying she
makes more money as an escort opposed to
Wall Street exactly yeah
but I'm wondering three thousand dollars
for two hours with her yeah my guess is
two hours long enough right I don't need
two hours how much for 30 minutes
yeah that's um 30 minutes and you kick
rocks it's like those camping beds two
hours I'm like hey hey what the [__] no
it's over is this my guess for three
grand person she may not yeah three
grand good deal not quite as bright
oh I see what you're saying once you get
in the she's cool there's a you know
there you go
Not Looking Back in life thinking I wish
I did things more interesting okay sweet
quote okay all good
that's that's why it's alarming how she
blurs out the eyes like I know it's like
this is right there hold on just go go
back for a sec which one just go back
right there in the white shirt I know
what you're talking about go down she's
all sweaty she looks like she just
ordered your death and she's eight she
she runs the Chinese Mafia I said it I
like it she does she looks like
she was like
I'll throw that picture and go 3K yeah
right right let's talk down a thousand
that's yeah I'm gonna send that Pingo 3K
you serious yeah
3K smoking a cigar that's great all
right well there we go guys we did it
again we did it again thanks for
listening
um Brennan's gonna be in I'm in La Jolla
this Friday Saturday Sunday working on
the Lord's day Sunday wow two shows I
know it's crazy two shows Friday two
shows Saturday one show Sunday night in
La Jolla California The Comedy Store the
great comedy store right outside San
Diego come get you some right now see
you guys this week I can't wait with my
favorite venues tickets at thickboy.com
uh I'll be in uh Comedy Works the end of
the month June 29 June 13th July 1. see
you love you guys